hi yah yah yah yah yah yah Oh
[Music]
welcome to alpha 3 is that talking about
the gamers I'm talking about the town
like there's some weird segmented series
of towns here and this is the third oh
[ __ ] oh hi hello oh you look tired also
stupid
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa hello neighbor
hi oh [ __ ] well that got more insane why
do i buy this house oh man man the land
value in this neighborhood must be [ __ ]
if that's what we're looking at oh my
god well hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to hello
neighbor
it's been a while uh since I played and
there's been a lot of changes I imagine
so I'm just gonna go right over and say
hi hello I'm new to the neighborhood
oh god this is drastically different oh
god everything's different
hello I'm just gonna barge in your home
hope you don't mow [ __ ] me hello hi I
remember there be I remember there being
mannequins but I don't remember there
being anything loo ah okay this is
bizarre oh yeah let's keep the lights
off I like to make it creepier in my
Breaking and Entering [ __ ] hello hi
Wow I [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] well I
guess he was gentle about it I heard a
gasp and then he moved on good for him I
guess who just hears his mildly
concerned that somebody was in his house
okay well that's a thing I guess he just
picked me up with his big strong arms
and moved to be back outside to my place
well okay oh this has not been taken
care of
oh man the art style is drastically
improved I must I must admit I'm just
gonna steal his milk and his broom and
his pot of everything let's move along
oh geez
why is this here I can't even move that
can I move that anymore why can't I move
anything anymore
why is everything sort of locked down in
here okay well somewhere [ __ ] I'm not
in your
you're in my house I'm just unpacking
was looking for help yeah well yeah okay
forgive and forget
okay well least I have a house now hello
nine-one-one I'm breaking into my
neighbor's house oh very dark oh geez
well I goofed cuz I have no idea where
my thing is nope I don't know what that
is what I think it's really stupid
oh I have to press and hold to pick up
oh hey neighbor
you want some glue is it sticky ah
sticky I never hey yeah what was that
I'm going in yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah okay so
he's not up here I know oh [ __ ] oh no I
said I'll lock down now well how am I
gonna be able to get how am I gonna be
able to get anywhere okay so this is
saying that's key and an apple maybe oh
[ __ ] hi I don't like this place at all
nothing here is cool absolutely
everything in this house is terrifying
and I don't know why I should be here
but I'm looking for a key apple an apple
key oh [ __ ] I didn't I didn't do that
bad [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stop
good god it's so scary now is it never
gonna be daytime it's our key in the
Apple is the Apple a key I'm gonna bring
this Apple as a goodwill offering do you
like mine apfel Oh scheisse oh thank you
no thank you there's no reason to be
upset there is no reason to be upset
alright then
okay all right well just gonna go in
your house again you are a trusting
individual and I like that I like that a
loss I've got an oh I didn't do that
marks to apfel okay
so I think this is a lie unless there's
another Apfel somewhere here oh no what
is this
hello what [ __ ] didn't mean to throw
that whoa okay all right then don't mind
I'm just gonna go into my neighbor's
house and watch TV I mean is that a
crime
probably [ __ ] why are [ __ ] god damn
it [ __ ] ah [ __ ] why still got your
remote [ __ ] well what are you gonna do
when your TV's turning on and off
randomly and you have no idea how to
control it you'll never have any control
in your life anymore oh oh he's stuck in
his own bear trap like an idiot okay
well I'm not doing either what are you
doing well we turn off [ __ ] off yeah
that's right that's right yeah what are
you doing huh nothing yeah me neither
good we just get a good look at that ass
ah let me get a good look at that
struttin ass oh he knows oh he knows I'm
watching ah ah okay bye
he's going back over there let me go to
this kitchen maybe there's a I mean the
hey come on now come on come on now whoa
hey hey hey
hey hey oh [ __ ] you don't like that oh
what's what you gonna do neighbor huh
huh you're bitching you can't cross that
line huh Oh
if you cross that line I'm on I will
give it to you [ __ ] I'm gonna give
throw a couple haymakers your way come
on come and me
[ __ ] off get some yeah get some okay so
are you gonna go you're gonna go you're
gonna go bro huh yeah what you could
take one more step on a call to police
I'm gonna call the police
yeah that's right walk away well well
well well well well well well whoa whoa
whoa whoa I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened there but whoa
sir way to get into my own bedroom maybe
I could just take a nap and be done with
all this wake up in the morning when I
could actually see something I'm just
gonna go to bed well I can't do that
anymore that doesn't exist as an option
well I need to get inside there I need
to find a way inside I need to find a
key or something I need to find a
flashlight that's what I need to find oh
I just noticed why is his car crashed
into his yard did the oh [ __ ] why
fine you know what kill me I don't even
- oh hey that was uncomfortably close
okay so I bet in his kitchen somewhere
it's got to be a secret apple whoo
that's a flashlight Oh perfect
Oh perfect Oh perfect yes okay so I've
got a flashlight
which hopefully means that I'm gonna be
able to find what I need a photo shoot
so this is better I'll be it a little
scarier so I just got to make sure that
I'm not where he is because if I do that
then I'm gonna die but I can take you
now okay least that unlocks the back
door which is good okay so making
progress oh my god he's got a glue
collection they say oh that's glue
[Music]
well I did something I don't know what I
did but I don't know if I should have
done Ditka where does this wire go wire
wire where do you lead oh my god you go
higher oh did that open the gate
oh that might have opened the gate oh
that's Mike whoa okay gonna ring around
the rosey how close is he Jesus how fast
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's fast you're not
allowed to be that fast well so what is
what is that oh it's a cup of coffee
okay
alright then carry on whatever the hell
you decide to do you carry on and do it
cuz I'm about through your [ __ ] why
did I do
oh the flashlight duh he can see that
okay alright goodbye good night
good night neighbor good night good
night neighbor I'm gonna make it in
there I'm gonna get up there I'm gonna
get up I'm gonna get up and do the thing
with the thing and the people and the
thing can you get out of your front lawn
I'd appreciate that thank you
sneaky sneaky whoosh okay whoosh like a
boy ADA and [ __ ] did he turn off he
might have turned off the thing [ __ ]
[ __ ] who's knocking on the other side of
that goddamn door okay so this is on
what does that mean I don't know what
them [ __ ] where is he
[ __ ] scheisse scheisse scheisse scheisse
what about that door what about that one
huh-huh it doesn't work oh yeah wait
[ __ ] does it oh it does yeah
okay well that's terrifying why am I in
here what's in here Oh Oh [ __ ]
backdoor hell yes ah [ __ ]
god damnit you sack of tits okay well I
found a back door in so that's good and
it seems like it don't know what that
did but it seems like it procedurally
unlocks things throughout the house I
hear him oh see play oh [ __ ] nevermind
hi so this seems like it procedurally
unlocks things throughout the house so
maybe whoa [ __ ] hell okay Jesus he
just spawns in a random location how am
I supposed to know no he spawns in his
front door apparently there's got to be
another way in that I can go but I'm
gonna go around the side just take my
chair with me my stealth chair sneaky
peek you like it this is not sneaky
peeky
the opposite - sneaky peeky so it's
obviously not this but there's a switch
on the other side I just got to get to
it
oh hello hi where'd you come from
there's got to be a way there's it's
obviously a clue Apple and key so
there's got to be a Golden Apple and
that's a key oh good I'm smart that's
not good I'll lose him oh I'm not gonna
lose him apparently yeah I'm here he'll
never find me here yeah he'll never be
me I got a chair oh boy
well wash what - fire hi oh alright dad
oh no Annelle having their mother get up
come on get down with the sickness your
father get up come on get down with the
sickness or in these rooms Oh have not
been in here yet we just take this chair
again put that somewhere else right
there whoa sneaky peeky who can't see
his thing
okay who is this where he takes his
rub-a-dub-dub man what kind of funky bed
is this okay why why would it be so
lifted turn a key more flashlight huh
Apple Apple Apple Apple
I found an apple it's that Apple was the
key this mean I found the key oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] way up five [ __ ]
okay well let's took out the Apple bow
so that's good so maybe I can take this
Apple and I'll be able to do something
with it to the door get a key
whatever was knock knock knockin on
heaven's door up there tonight
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't move so you're
gonna have to come to me okay alright
then [ __ ]
okay so there's got to be a way please
don't be around this corner please don't
be around this corner so goodbye hi
goddamnit how am I supposed to be able
to get in there what I know is I gotta
be like patient about it or something so
this is meaningless Apple keys hello
hello oh wait that's a different apples
but the one I brought before ah okay so
there's there's some sort of secret here
but I'm not getting it another flash
like glue a bong eyeballs woo hello
that's interesting why why what did he
do where did he do it oh hey
all righty then I like how it's the
exact same sounds from Slenderman so
long ago least I got at least I can
explore my house now that's kind of nice
ooh I've got an upstairs who knew can I
open it I cannot for some reason I can't
open my own upstairs that's good hello
what I can't pick up my own goddamn
flashlight again what I just threw it oh
god damn it
well I gotta go get another one he's
gonna be in the [ __ ] way
it's still t Lilly dananananana I'm
Sophie nananana nananana I'm sneaking in
a nanana nanana
no one will find me huh hey hey I don't
know if I was supposed to do that but it
worked
yay so okay Matt did who is it nope okay
nothing I saw an apple
I thought maybe but barely not who oh
[ __ ]
well he can't give me here maybe I have
no idea maybe yeah yeah well I doesn't
help anybody okay well we're in trouble
oh [ __ ] me there's a golden lock oh [ __ ]
a weight more wire oh wait that wire
that I was that I was doing the thing
for that goes all the way over here this
goes nowhere except down well he's he's
angry about all that fell down okay
there's nothing there why are there
windows on the ceiling yeah but either
way though the wire does run all the way
over there oh hello
okay house to house upside down eight
left 24 down ah lambda orange in blue so
portal 8 left 24 down half-life and then
portal if M is that's what I'm gathering
from that plop [ __ ] well that stupid
[ __ ] I am done goofed myself Oh
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] right then let's try that
again
shoo boo boo laughs [ __ ] y ver y ver
chit chit chit chit chit chit chit hey
whoa hey friend let me try this again II
[ __ ] god damn it such an owl Hey
hello oh he's gone oh so oh oh I can't
get fat oh come on how in the [ __ ] do I
get that yeah okay well that's a big old
bag of dicks what do I do about that
okay
well [ __ ] I found where the key is that
guy knocked down his face
none of these work I've I've
accidentally oh maybe something behind
the paintings maybe like in the house
like the paintings are important like
anything that could possibly be behind
the paintings maybe I'm really reaching
here but you know now that I know that
there could be things behind the
paintings so this is a Gold Lion
anything by there no alrighty then lamp
no alright windows this does not work 8
left 24 down lambda horseshoe I don't
know what this means this is a clue to
something I just don't know what it is
so there's a clue here and there's
something that I could do uh but what is
it what is it I've explored a bit and
I've made some progress but I don't feel
like it's nearly enough for what I've
done
so there's a hole in the wall and I need
a grabber to be able to get through that
I've got eyes staring at me
oh hello you're never gonna get me shut
up and be stupid
then I've got this switch but I turn the
power off so I can't open this gate
anymore but I could open the gate if I
turn the power back on then I'd be able
to have some lights in the house you'll
never get me ha ha ha look at you all
you're so stuck
whoo shitty is he literally bashing that
open eventually I don't think he is so
either way that's all the time I got for
this episode here I am gonna try this
more in the future I am gonna penetrate
the defenses of this game and I kind of
want to find it out for myself but if I
get super stuck I will look it up so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]